okay guys it's been a while uh that's me
big movies have been now but now we have
a nice big movie with robots fighting
and stuff called Real Steel and I'm
gonna tell you my real review of it and
really the only way to properly sum it
up and to see if you guys would like it
is to just tell you the climax just just
the setup for the climax okay so it's
the future you have in this big boxing
ring you have this giant super mega
robot named Zeus the all-time champion
machine and in the other corner
this tiny innocent little robot with a
stitch down smile who nobody thought
would go anywhere but went all the way
in here he is at the championship and on
that side you have Hugh Jackman he used
to be a boxer but now he's a nobody
nobody gives him a chance he owes money
all over town but here he is the
championship and on the other side you
got the evil asian guy controlling Zeus
he's there with all his controls and all
his little afterburner effects while
Hugh Jackman's over there just using his
fists because it has a shadow boxing
option and he's literally in there
fighting in the ring and the asian guy
is there just punching through the
windows he's so angry and to the side is
it's the evil lover this Russian woman
who's sitting there shaking her head
going no impossible
impossible and over on Hugh Jackman's
side you have the cute little kid again
who came from nothing just lost his
mommy
looking at the championship looking at
his daddy with a tear in his eye in
slow-mo mind you with the glorious music
playing and also in the stands you have
Hugh Jackman's girlfriend who also has
tears in her eyes shaking her head going
my god my god I never thought they would
make it this far that's the setup for
the climax now if at any of that
you said okay that either sounds like
really good drama or enjoyably
stupid-ass silly you're gonna love this
movie cuz that's all the movie is it's
all that eighties cheese all those movie
constructed cliches that are a ton of
fun and I think they're a ton of fun
because there's so much passion put into
it there's you get the feeling that the
people making this movie like really
believe in these cliches they really
believe in these lines you know the
scene where Hugh Jackman you know looks
at the foster parent something says just
give me one more chance you know I mean
it's those great over-the-top hammy
moment it it's like rocky for it's like
The Wizard
it's like all that schmaltz I felt like
Sylvester Stallone directed this that's
what kind of movie it is there's even a
scene where the Asian guy in the Russian
girlfriend who literally are Drago and
the Russian girlfriend a you know from
Rocky for there's a scene where you know
he comes out he's got his Herald spiked
up and he's got the cool clothes and
stuff and he points to the big robot zu
st. says anything he sees he kills and
okay that's taken right from Rocky for
with anything he touches he destroys
it's like almost word-for-word they
changed like two words it's like the
exact same thing it's that kind of
happiness now when that said if you
heard that set up for that climax said
that is the stupidest most cliched
dumbest thing I've ever heard in my life
that's what you're gonna think of the
movie that pretty much how it works and
the funny thing is that it starts out
surprisingly you're sort of taking it
seriously used for whatever reason sort
of accept this world we're just robots
can fight they do nothing else in this
future which is very odd I don't know if
that's actually a really clever
commentary or really silly one or both
but you know and Hugh Jackman's down on
his luck and and he's always good I mean
I it's funny I realize he's I've never
seen him like incredible like great
acting wise I've never seen my Broadway
here he's great but
I'd never seen him like you know really
phenomenal but he's never bad I just
realized I'd never see a movie that he
specifically was banned and maybe there
is or maybe it's coming up but and yeah
it starts off like you're almost taking
it seriously and you have the woman from
laws - I'm always gonna refer to as the
woman from lost there at the gym and and
they talked seriously I like how they
talk about getting the main event no I
want this one there's a lot of business
talk about these robots which I like is
it makes it seem almost real so it
starts out almost credible it's like
okay if you just accept this stupid idea
that robots are fighting now which maybe
isn't that stupid the more I think about
it you could see it happening you're
still buying into it but then as soon as
the kid enters into the picture the kid
is a total construct of movies and film
ID it's just it's the kid that talks
like Fred Savage from The Wizard I mean
just has this unbelievable vocabulary
just it's smarter than anyone else and
way too freakin smart in fact there's
one scene I think after he watches Zeus
fight and he comes out and for thirty
seconds he's a real kid he said did you
see that that that was awesome he's in
there and he's fighting and he's just
wasn't a bomb I mean he's actually
talking like a real kid that's how a
real kid would talk that's only three
seconds of the movie the rest of the
film
he's Fred Savage he's Macaulay Culkin
he's that Android he's more robotic than
the robots but I think that's what they
were looking for so I have no idea if
this movie was intentionally cheesy it
is intentionally like Karate Kid 3 or
something like that whether it was or
not if that gives you an idea about what
you'll think of it
I'm trying what else the effects
surprisingly are really good you sort of
seem in the previews again alright more
transformers of fags whatever seen that
I know they're not really there a lot of
times they look like they're there which
is very impressive I mean for giant
moving robots being the crap out of each
other which we've seen over and over
again
I thought the effects are actually
pretty good until the end I think when
you get all the lights flashing and the
cameras circling around and stuff like
that I mean that
it's like okay this is this is computer
they're not there um but on top of that
the fighting is good and they sort of
show you the strategy you know which is
nice because if the robots are fighting
yeah hugh jackman the kid and they're
talking about what to do they're
discussing the strategy and I like that
I think that's you know you look at the
Rocky movies or any boxing movie you
know the strategy is always just when
they go to the side and they talk about
what they're gonna do I like that during
the fight they're talking about how to
maneuver out of this or how to fight
back I think that's really clever
um again until the EM which is just
there's no strategy it's just the robot
suddenly has a little power and that's
really and they play off the fact
whether or not the robot is kind of a
live there's a scene where they set him
up and they have his head facing a
mirror and they just have a close-up of
him looking at the mirror it's that's
the kind of movie this is and I loved it
I probably laughing way too hard
throughout this film um but I saw with
just the right audience I saw with the
audience that as soon as like the robot
hit another robot or in this case like a
bull's pull fight in the south big shock
with this robot and and I just heard the
people behind me just go Oh at the first
part gassing this with the right crowd
because you know people are cheering on
the robot whatever he gets back and it's
I saw just the right crowd and I
remember afterwards and I'll say I saw a
bar go and we were just laughing the
whole way through and I just said that
was fantastic Lachey every over-the-top
line everything you know that light and
the people behind me that were cheering
throughout the whole film just I thought
I know right isn't it great so I think
the people who are cheering for and
having fun they knew this was really
silly too but it worked out really well
if you like that stuff so if you don't
like that stuff if you want to see
something you can really take seriously
and stuff like that go see something you
can take seriously I think by watching
the trailers you'll know to stay away
from this but if you're looking for good
cheese and there's a lot of passion put
into it I think it's not half-assed you
know all the cliches of course have been
done to death
they're laughable but it's not
half-assed they're putting a lot into a
huge Ackman again it's taking it totally
seriously um and there actually is a
connection between him and the boy and
even with the girlfriend stuff like that
so the the connections are there and you
are served rooting for the robot you
want to see him get through and stuff
like that so uh it gets his job done um
yeah that's really about it so it's sort
of like the first Transformers movie if
you look at the trailer say hey I think
I'll like this you'll probably like it
if you look at and say hey this looks
really fucking stupid you're gonna think
it's fucking stupid so uh guys that's
about it take it for what it's worth a
nice show talk to you later